[Music]
dude we're still working on him i worked
on him myself he's perfect drop in dude
now
[Music]
who are you
catchphrase
well that time thing went up yet well
the catchphrase as a catchphrase is a
pretty cool catchphrase
am i a role model
i don't know i mean i do know that you
hear about actors complaining about how
hard their movie workouts are
and i'll tell you i don't have time for
that i've been at this one week
and i gotta tell you
it's coming in nicely
[Music]
i start every day with a protein bomb
it's made exclusively of human muscle
it's completely organic and illegal
acting is
mind over matter
and judgment
and common sense
sure i don't fit into the deadpool suit
anymore
but life is about growth
hormones
[Music]
i actually fathered our youngest
daughter when i was this muscular
the child was born
full-grown
and wearing shoes
which was weird for blake
[Music]
who is this i don't know i mean he's
just like you but way better with the
movie you think he's gonna
hit you he punches so hard but yeah his
hands are so salty
boom
my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys and
i live
in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work at the bank
i thought i had everything i needed
but then i met her
everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
please i have a goldfish there's
something inside you guys i don't want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules but you are so
much more than that put these on okay
fine
oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something
guy there is no easy way to say this
this world it's a video game you're not
real
pleased
[Applause]
and the guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters i am
sitting here with my best friend trying
to help him get through a tough time now
if that's not real i don't know what it
is
i know this world is just a game for
this place these people that's all i
have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy thanks
guys i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity off you go
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before i really wish you'd
mention that
that actually hurt my hand we can save
our world but we have to fight together
[Music]
no
[Applause]
i can't die
[Music]
[Music]
you